from the ocean it appears even more
menacing the evacuation cordon around
the kumbreva volcanic eruption in
spain's la palma island is widening
extending two nautical miles into the
sea
fishing boats are docked bringing the
port town to a standstill
fisherman nicolas luis perez is worried
that a giant wave of lava could submerge
the zacorte
we are afraid we don't know how things
will evolve there is such a rich
biodiversity here and it is scary to see
that they are evacuated people in these
areas
with at least two active craters
volcanic activity is intensifying liquid
lava is overflowing and a cloud of ash
is shooting four kilometers into the sky
grounding all commercial flights
more villages are being evacuated
putting spain's guardia seville on high
alert
from the coast the volcano sounds like a
huge crashing wave and with each
explosions at times comes a sonic boom
shaking windows you can feel it in your
body and soak in the wildlife in the
ocean
the eruption is reverberating into the
ocean sensing danger are rare blue
sharks and pilot whales if the 1 000
degrees celsius lava continues its path
to the cold atlantic ocean scientists
predict a thermal shock sending plumes
of toxic chemicals into the air killing
many of the life beneath and in its
vicinity
we could see a delta of lava flowing
into the ocean while this would cause an
explosion in the short term eventually
in the long term it will bring new
minerals into the ocean and bring back
more biodiversity to marine life
ignoring the possible dangers tourists
flocked to the islands attracted by the
volcanic landscape the unusually black
sandy beaches are the result of previous
eruptions
some on the island would refer to cumbre
vieja as the sleeping beauty now awoken
it is showing its true nature powerful
and unpredictable nicholas honk al
jazeera
la palma spain